spacex turns 20 years old in a few
months and elon has certainly made a lot
of progress in that time but big things
have small beginnings the early days
were incredibly difficult for the
company test launches kept failing
suppliers weren't delivering and
bankruptcy was always just around the
corner there was even a group of drunk
russians who almost ruined everything
but we'll get to that story in a minute
the early history of spacex is a
powerful lesson in the importance of
perseverance so let's go back to the
year 2000 and the very beginning of
spacex
it was october and elon musk who was
serving as the ceo of paypal at the time
was in sydney australia to watch the
olympic games with his girlfriend this
wasn't great timing though paypal was in
turmoil as executives and investors
argued over which direction to take the
company this battle came to a head while
he was still seven thousand miles away
from the office and by the time he made
it back to palo alto he was out of a job
getting fired from paypal was definitely
not part of elon's plan but there was a
silver lining he had always been
interested in space travel and now that
he wasn't in charge of a growing company
he could spend as much time as he wanted
exploring his true passions it was a bit
of a blessing in disguise since what he
would go on to build at spacex would be
dramatically more ambitious than paypal
but it would require a ton of work so he
started studying first he joined a space
advocacy nonprofit called the mars
society the organization was filled with
tons of scientists and researchers who
were obsessed with space travel and the
colonization of mars in particular
elon didn't want to just talk about
space exploration though he actually
wanted to do it so he started pitching
an idea he called the mars oasis his
plan was to send a small greenhouse to
mars that would grow plants in martian
soil elon believed that if people saw
concrete evidence that life was possible
on the red planet it would reinvigorate
interest in space exploration after we
landed a man on the moon and the space
race came to a close nasa funding fell
significantly and no one was seriously
working on mars colonization so elon got
to work he needed a rocket and not just
any rocket a big one so he assembled a
crack team of experts to help him find
the ideal rocket he first phoned adeo
resi who was one of his friends from
upenn back in his college days but adeo
didn't have any space experience so elon
called jim cantrell cantrell had worked
on various joint missile defense
programs conducted between america and
russia and was perfect for this job
there was only one problem he thought
elon was crazy see when cantrell first
picked up the phone elon told him that
he was a billionaire which he wasn't yet
who wanted to save humanity by sending
rockets to mars it sounded like the
ravings of a madman so cantrell was very
wary to meet elon in person just to be
safe he insisted that they meet at the
denver airport behind the security
checkpoint so he could guarantee that
elon wouldn't have any weapons on him
fortunately once they sat down and had a
chance to talk through elon's full
vision cantrell was convinced and agreed
to help out so the three of them flew to
paris where they met with a french
aerospace company to discuss the
purchase of a rocket but the only
rockets available were over a hundred
million dollars each even though elon
was rich he wasn't that rich yet he only
had about 30 million dollars which he
had made from the sale of his first
company zip2 so he had to find another
option the team then flew from paris to
moscow in hopes of finding a cheaper
rocket after the fall of the soviet
union demilitarization treaties required
that russia decommissioned thousands of
intercontinental ballistic missiles or
icbms these were well-designed rockets
and after you removed the nuclear
warhead from them they could definitely
be used as orbital launch vehicles while
they were in russia elon and his team
scheduled meetings with two separate
russian space organizations they thought
it would be easy to buy an old icbm
since they were basically just sitting
around useless at this point but
negotiations with the russians turned
out to be close to impossible i really
enjoyed adeo's account of the whole
fiasco he said then we started having
meetings with the russian space program
which is basically fueled by vodka we'd
all go into this little room and every
single person had his own bottle in
front of him they'd toast every two
minutes which means 20 or 30 toasts an
hour to space to america to america in
space i finally looked over at elon and
jim and they were passed out on the
table then i passed out myself it seemed
like a dead end but elon was willing to
do anything to get a deal done he spent
hours talking to the russians just in
order to get them to open up a bit about
what they actually had in stock and they
weren't exactly friendly to his
inquiries during one particularly heated
exchange one of the russians actually
spit on elon in disgust but even all
those ridiculous events in russia didn't
end negotiations entirely for the next
meeting the russians flew to los angeles
to meet with elon on his home turf but
they seemed more interested in partying
than doing business they reportedly
called him and asked for five thousand
dollars in cash to go clubbing for the
night now it's not exactly easy to
withdraw five grand from a bank on a
weekend and atms have limits but elon's
friend adeo knew someone who worked at
the mondrian in west hollywood and kept
lots of cash on hand it must have been a
ridiculous favor to ask someone to
borrow thousands of dollars from the
hotel safe but it worked the russians
were appeased and spent the night
partying for their third meeting elon
was more determined than ever it was
february of 2002 and at this point elon
had been trying to find a rocket for
over a year with no luck so he flew to
russia but this time he brought mike
griffin this guy was a space industry
veteran and actually went on to lead all
of nasa in 2005. griffin brought a level
of seriousness to the discussions that
helped move negotiations forward and
elon was finally able to get a quote
there was only one problem it was still
too high the russians wanted eight
million dollars for a single rocket elon
was willing to pay the eight million
dollars but for that price he wanted two
rockets the russians held firm to their
original pricing and wouldn't cut a deal
with elon so he stormed out of the
meeting into the freezing moscow air
outside and took a cab back to the
airport on the flight back to america
elon's team ordered a round of drinks to
celebrate getting out of russia alive
but elon wasn't celebrating he had his
laptop open and was already thinking
about his next step he started building
an xl model for rocket construction
costs and he found something incredible
only three percent of the cost of a
rocket came from raw materials like
aluminum and copper there were tons of
inefficiencies most of which could be
eliminated with careful planning
historically the space industry has
operated using a cost plus model which
means that the rocket manufacturer will
total up all of their costs and then add
a profit margin on top this leads to
perverse incentives though since the
higher your costs are the higher your
profits will be and governments are
notoriously bad at demanding lower costs
on that flight elon discovered that if
he streamlined the entire rocket
construction process and cut out the
inefficient subcontractors he could get
to orbit for a fraction of the
industry's standard cost even though
elon started by planning to go straight
to mars realistically he had to start
smaller so he settled on a small payload
rocket where he could prove out his
ideas before going bigger he'd been
tracking the industry for years and
found that until the 1990s the vast
majority of launches were transporting
large satellites usually for government
agencies there was no way elon could
afford to build a rocket big enough to
compete for these types of contracts at
least initially but satellites were
getting smaller increasingly smaller
telecommunications satellites were
providing critical connectivity to
private sector companies and elon
believed that for around 100 million
dollars he could build a rocket that
could get those satellites into orbit
that still wasn't a ton of money though
and a good portion of that was going to
need to go toward designing the rocket
engine luckily elon found the perfect
partner his name was tom mueller and
he'd been obsessed with building model
rockets since his childhood after
graduating from the university of idaho
with a degree in mechanical engineering
mueller moved to california and was
hired by trw while there mueller
developed several advanced liquid rocket
engines most notably the tr-106 which
generated 650 000 pounds of thrust it
was a huge achievement but after 15
years climbing the corporate ladder he
was ready for a change mueller wanted to
move faster and try out new ideas but
trw employed over a hundred thousand
people and was hesitant to take big
risks so mueller joined a group of
amateur rocket enthusiasts called the
reaction research society everyone had a
real hacker mindset and would drive out
to the mojave desert to launch rockets
they built in their own garages when
mueller was at one of these events he
met a man named john garvey the two hit
it off immediately and started working
together on nights and weekends on a
completely new idea they called it the
bfr which if you follow spacex at all
you probably know what that stands for
already now we don't know for sure but
rumor has it that the bfr was the
largest amateur rocket engine ever built
it could generate 12 000 pounds of
thrust and it was enough to impress elon
when he saw it in person in early 2002
it wasn't quite strong enough but it was
close elon wanted to deliver a half-ton
payload to orbit and needed 80 000
pounds of thrust to do it but he could
tell that mueller could deliver if he
just had a little bit more budget so
elon made both mueller and garvey job
offers to join spacex garvey declined
but mueller signed on as the first
official employee and vp of propulsion
the team wasn't complete yet though elon
would definitely need more talented
engineers to make his dream a reality so
he started recruiting an aerospace
engineer named chris thompson to work on
the body and structure of the rocket
thompson had worked at boeing and was
the perfect person for the job so he
joined spacex as employee number two
this new team immediately started
planning what would become the falcon 1.
the design criteria were pretty simple
the rocket needed to deliver a half-ton
satellite to orbit and not much else all
the reusability stuff you hear about
nowadays was still a long way away just
getting off the launch pad in one piece
would be a big enough challenge and the
falcon 1 had to do it on a shoestring
budget this was a blessing and a curse
though obviously it's tough to build a
big rocket without a big budget even
basic materials are extremely expensive
after all but the spacex team was
working from a blank slate so they
didn't have any legacy technology
weighing them down and they could design
completely from first principles they
still needed a bit more money though
elon's 30 million wasn't quite enough
luckily paypal was just about to go
public and elon had held on to a huge
stake in the company in february of 2002
the ipo went off flawlessly and elon
suddenly had an extra 165 million
dollars to play with and he wasn't about
to just sit on all that cash he
immediately went out and rented a thirty
thousand square foot warehouse in el
segundo california to use as a factory
hiring was also top of mind for elon so
he hired hans koningsman as his vp of
avionics before joining spacex
koenigsmann had worked at microcosm
developing low-cost rockets and knew
what it took to deliver quickly without
sacrificing on quality the pieces were
finally coming together so elon
registered spacex as a real company on
may 6th of 2002 to celebrate the
occasion elon threw a party with a
mariachi band in what looks like a
completely unfurnished office i guess
people don't need office chairs if
they're dancing with most of the
leadership team in place elon began
hiring more engineers to help with the
more technical aspects of rocket
development and his strategy here was
really brilliant he already had some
solid industry veterans in place so he
focused on engineering students with
zero work experience and he took a very
hands-on approach here personally
calling universities to get in contact
with the top performing students it's
hilarious to imagine getting a personal
phone call from elon musk when you're
sitting in your dorm room nowadays but
back then he was a complete no-name in
the aerospace industry taking chances on
young engineering students allowed elon
to keep costs low and he extended this
thinking into his entire business he
knew that the space industry had been
plagued by complex networks of
contractors and subcontractors if spacex
was going to succeed they would need to
do things differently and elon really
didn't hold back when it came to doing
things differently nearly all rockets
are manufactured horizontally but spacex
actually found that it would be cheaper
to build the entire rocket vertically
instead now there was some precedent for
this the russians did it this way but it
definitely challenged some common
knowledge here in the states but that's
the type of creative thinking you need
to employ if you're going to build a
rocket with 200 employees instead of 20
000 when you're understaffed the natural
reaction is to try and outsource more of
the work to third-party contractors but
elon really tried to do the opposite he
was constantly trying to bring any
expensive or time-consuming activity
in-house as soon as possible spacex even
spent 10 million dollars building a
welding workshop just so they could make
more critical rocket parts in-house this
strategy served them well and by early
2003 the first merlin engine was ready
for testing but they couldn't just turn
it on in the el segundo warehouse
there's always a risk of an engine
exploding so you need a big open space
to run a safe test and you know what
they say everything's bigger in texas
so spacex headed to mcgregor texas and
set up shop in a defunct rocket testing
facility the site was pretty well
equipped and even had a massive concrete
tripod for mounting rocket engines the
only problem was that mcgregor was 1400
miles from los angeles so every time the
spacex engineers wanted to run a test
they had to rent a hummer and tow the
engine for days just to get there it
wasn't easy but it got the job done at
least most of the time one test was cut
short by the united states secret
service they pulled up just as the
spacex team was about to turn on the
engine and stopped the test it turned
out that the merlin engine which had
been mounted on the tripod was pointing
directly at president bush's ranch which
wasn't far from mcgregor they must have
had some pretty good intel to pick up
the engine from so far away but the
incident led the spacex team to make
sure to inform the local community
before each test fire even though spacex
now had a viable engine testing facility
they still needed a place to actually
launch the rockets they initially looked
at vandenberg air force base in
california which would have been great
because it's so close to the main spacex
headquarters but like always there was a
problem a titan 4 rocket with a one
billion dollar spy satellite on board
was sitting on the launch pad just
waiting to get launched the schedule for
this satellite was constantly shifting
and until it took off spacex couldn't do
anything the air force was worried that
if the spacex launch failed debris from
the explosion could damage the billion
dollar satellite elon and his team spent
six months waiting for the air force to
clear the launch site but eventually
they got frustrated and started looking
for a new option they had already
scouted a few potential launch pads in
the pacific and one location stood out
in particular it was the kwajalein atoll
in the marshall islands and it satisfied
a lot of key criteria it had already
been used as a missile defense test site
and was close to the equator so spacex
started refurbishing the facilities in
late 2005 and began to prepare for the
launch of falcon 1. at this point spacex
was already a few years behind schedule
the original plan was to launch the
first rocket by october of 2003 but that
didn't matter to elon he was still
moving incredibly fast by industry
standards in early 2006 the spacex team
packed up the falcon 1 and shipped it to
kwajalein by boat once it arrived the
engineers completed the final assembly
and were ready to launch elon gathered
with his team to watch the launch and at
first everything went smoothly
[Music]
the first stage merlin engine ignited
and the rocket lifted off but just 33
seconds later the engine caught fire and
exploded even though this was the first
flight ever elon was so confident that
it would work he had loaded the rocket
with a fully functional satellite which
crashed through the roof of a shed on
the island after digging through the
wreckage engineers found the culprit
responsible for the explosion it was a
single corroded bolt which had been
overlooked during inspections even
though this launch was a failure the
spacex team still went out for drinks to
celebrate the milestone they got back to
work pretty quickly and just a few weeks
later the team was ready for launch
number two but traveling to quad is not
easy the trip from los angeles required
a five-hour flight to hawaii an
overnight layover another flight to the
marshall islands and then a military
transport ferry to get to the actual
atoll and island life on this tiny
military outpost doesn't quite compare
to los angeles since it's a military
site there aren't really any tourists
and the island basically only has two
hotels the rooms are run down and the tv
only shows military channels there are
two bars on the island and i'm sure that
after a few weeks the spacex employees
basically knew everyone on a first name
basis but what the island lacks in
entertainment it more than makes up for
with its beautiful nature spacex
employees would spend their time going
scuba diving and exploring the coral
reefs during world war ii a german
cruiser ship had sunk in the lagoon and
became a beautiful artificial reef
perfect for curious spacex divers to
explore on march 21 2007 spacex launched
their second falcon 1 rocket this time
they were a bit more realistic about
their odds of success and used a dummy
payload instead of a customer satellite
the first and second stages both fired
successfully this time but about four
minutes into the flight the rockets
started to wobble the merlin engine kept
working for another three minutes but
ultimately failed to push the rocket
into a proper orbit one year later
spacex tried for a third time and again
they failed to deliver the rocket to
orbit the first stage was working
perfectly but after it's separated from
the second stage it kept accelerating
which caused the two pieces to smash
into each other this must have been a
crushing defeat for the entire spacex
team they had been working for years on
this project and couldn't get it to work
even worse the company was now about to
run out of money elon knew he was close
though and really wanted to get one more
launch together so he called up his
paypal co-founder peter thiel and got
him to invest 20 million dollars in the
company now this might sound like a lot
of money for most startups but at spacex
it would only cover a few months of
expenses so they had to work quickly
there was a glimmer of hope on the
horizon though nasa was about to award a
massive 1.6 billion dollar contract for
12 supply runs to the international
space station all the usual big names
would be competing for the contract but
nasa was open to giving a startup like
spacex a real shot this was the chance
that elon needed to save the company but
there was no way he could win the
contract without a successful launch
under his belt there was simply no time
to build an entirely new falcon one from
scratch but spacex did have a spare
rocket in the la factory so the team
packed up the rocket and rented a
military cargo plane to fly the rocket
to the launch site a small group of
spacex employees rode inside the plane
with the rocket and it's good that they
did as the plane started to descend they
noticed that dents were starting to form
in the rocket's body the pressure levels
inside the rocket were destabilizing and
it could implode at any minute so one of
the engineers stepped up to fix the
problem and in doing so probably saved
the entire company he climbed inside the
rocket and used a wrench to open a valve
that equalized the pressure the plane
landed safely and the rocket was still
in one piece so after a few minor
repairs spacex was ready to launch this
time around everything worked perfectly
this was elon's last chance to keep
spacex alive and he'd done it spacex had
just become the first commercial company
in history to design build and launch a
liquid-fueled rocket to orbit
that fourth launch marked a turning
point for spacex just a few months later
elon and his brother kimball were on a
family trip to disneyland when elon
received a phone call it was nasa spacex
had just won the 1.6 billion contract
this changed everything for spacex even
though they wouldn't receive all the
money up front it provided predictable
cash flow and allowed them to attract
investors and employees spacex was now a
real space company and they could start
working on bigger projects like the
falcon 9 dragon capsule and starship i
love the story of spacex because it's
all about perseverance watching a rocket
that you spent years designing and
building go up in flames just a few
minutes after launch has to be crushing
but elon never let that get him down he
always found a way to get one more
chance because he knew what he was
building was worth fighting for if you
want to learn more about spacex just
drop your email at johncoogan.com and
please check out this recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks you'll
really like it